We have stuff like aloe, eggplants, the tomato will be ready soon.
Lots of celery, there is a lot of stuff, right?
[Guillaume] Sensei, do you cook?
I don't cook, I eat [laughs]
All the herbs will bloom like this.
I'm glad that we're meeting today!
[Guillaume] It's a gorgeous day, right?
Yes.
[Guillaume] Sensei, when were you born?
I was born on January 1st, 1940.
Even though I was born in Tokyo, we moved to the countryside during War.
I could play in the mountain, and in rivers since I was small until I was about 7 years old, so I love nature.
When it got better, we moved.
My parents didn't practice budo.
My sibling didn't practice it either.
It started for me because I liked to do many things by myself like swordplay or swimming.
I liked to walk in the mountain and swim in the river.
You went back to Tōkyō at age 7, how was life there after the war?
Yes, I went back to Tokyo since I was 7 years old, yes.
Japan had lost the war,
it was a period of reconstruction so there was no food,
it was very difficult.
However, I feel that it turned out to be a good thing because I was able to experience a simple life, so I'm grateful.
We became one with nature
so I think that these were happy times.
[Guillaume] Were you able to attend school for long?
I didn't.
I couldn't go to up to university.
Everyone was poor, so most children weren't be able to afford higher education.
I stopped at junior high.
My mother and father didn't have money so I could not stay idle.
I did a lot of part time jobs such as delivering milk...
Do you know about fermented soy beans?
[Guillaume] Yes, I do.
I went to pick it up and to sell it, it was fun.
Natto is at the top of the food pyramid because it's the healthiest, so on the contrary, I was very happy.
[Guillaume] Do you still eat it?
Yes still I eat it now.
Brown rice too, I'm fortunate because I learned to appreciate simple foods.
[Guillaume] Did you first start practicing budō at school?
Yes, I started with Judo during junior high school,
around 14 or 16 years old.
I just did a little bit at school, but I didn't like the aspects of winning or losing.
After that I did Kendo, I found it really interesting.
Kendo was fun.
The teacher gave me a very strange feeling.
The shinai is made of soft bamboo, right?
Even though he hit me lightly, the tip of the shinai reached all the way to my back.
He was a high ranked teacher.
When I saw that I thought that it was really interesting.
Even with minimal strength, it went all the way around.
My back hurt! [laughs]
It was fun.
From that point I read a lot of old books and I saw that
the old warriors would throw 60kg rice bags using the tip of their spear, like this.
It seems that such a thing really happened, and I thought it was interesting to see that, and that's how I became interested in martial arts.
[Guillaume] From there, you got into aikidō?
Yes. During that time, I was doing lots of sports, athletics, swimming, and I was having fun,
but was wondering if I could learn something more like budo like what I've described like the stuff with the spear or the shinai.
At that time I read an advertisement about Aikido that had come out in a newspaper.
It was rather mysterious stuff.
So I went there straight away.
[Guillaume] Were there any photos in that ad?
No there weren't any, just writing.
[Guillaume] So that made it mysterious...
Yes, that's it, mysterious!
How was the atmosphere during practice back then?
It was very interesting even though I didn't know anything about it!
Aikido wasn't very popular yet,
so there weren't many students, but the teachers were amazing.
People like the now-deceased Tamura Sensei who then went to France, many of them were still beginners, shodan max.
There were people like the Ki No Kenkyukai's Tohei Koichi Sensei,
Yamaguchi Sensei as well, and also people like Tada Sensei.
Tada Sensei said that he decided to do Aikido professionally after he finished university.
It was that generation, it was a really happy time.
Yes, Arikawa Sensei too was there. [laughs]
[Guillaume] You learnt many different styles, right?
There were a lot of great teachers.
They didn't care if you were poor and had no money, they just loved Aikido.
[Guillaume] Where was the dojo located in Tokyo?
The Sankei Dojo?
[Guillaume] Yes.
It was... do you know Yurakucho?
[Guillaume] Yes I do.
It was just underground from where the bullet train starts running.
[Guillaume] I was a popular place, right?
That's right it was in...
[Guillaume] There were many office workers?
It was in Ginza.
[Guillaume] A busy place...
Yes, there were many interesting people there.
I heard that famous people like the famous writer Nishima Yukio and the sumōtori turned wrestler Rikidōzan were training there at the time.
They weren't in that dojo, I mean that they were in the room next door.
They did it there.
[Guillaume] It wasn't Aikido?
No. It was Rikitozan, so he did that sort of [physical] training.
[Guillaume] The sumo...
Nishima Yukio was doing "hey!", "hey!" with a thick wooden sword.
[Guillaume] Ah, you never practiced together...
I never did, they were from a completely different world.
[Guillaume] Did you ever speak to them?
Yes, but just things like "hello" or "good morning".
[Guillaume] What sort of impression did you get from those people?
Hmm... I don't know really. I thought they were strange people.
Rikutozan was a famous person, a "national hero"
I didn't know much about Nishima Yukio yet.
He had some private soldiers from the Self Defense Force around him.
He was training to fight with a real enemy using real swords.
At same time though, he wrote some wonderful and beautiful books.
I thought that he looked interesting.
[Guillaume] We have this image of Mishima as a sensitive writer, but also as a rather enthusiastic right-wing martial artist. I wonder whether those two aspects of his personality as a Japanese were distinct depending on the context he was in.
It was the same. Even though he did "hey!" In Japan we think that you have to take care of your heart and your spirit.
Japan lost the Second World War but it also defeated the heart of the Japanese people. They said that it shouldn't be.
The Emperor always said that we should all get along with the people of the world but the Japanese forgot that.
It was during the time when the Americans said that Japanese people were no good.
But he wrote beautiful novels, really beautiful novels.
[Guillaume] I thought that budō had a bad image among the Japanese population for a long time because of its ties to what happened during the war.
In fact, I don't think Japanese people thought about martial arts much because martial arts had already become part of their normal lives,
but due to the fact that the General Headquarters, the Supreme Commander for the Allied Powers forbade kendo and the rest
We forgot the good things about kendo, that it wasn't about killing each other.
That's a bit unfortunate.
It's not a technique to kill each other, it's originally meant to clean the soul.
How is it that the meaning of budō got to be so misused or misunderstood?
I don't know how it used to be,
but originally, Japanese people didn't really like killing people
but it was the war so train their body so that they wouldn't lose, right?
That was the reason.
[Guillaume] The Second Dōshu actually considered the positive aspects of budō as a way to restore Japanese self-esteem.
It's about self-esteem, not material things.
I really think so.
Well, food is important, but we threw away our self-esteem and spirit
and even though I was just a child, it saddened me.
[Guillaume] About Rikidōzan, there seem to have been a connection between him and Tōhei Sensei. I always wonder whether other famous people like him were interested in aikidō.
Well, in fact, over there, many people practiced things like Judo or Karate were able to enter and do Aikido and they found it wonderful.
People like O Sensei or Tohei Sensei were there
and even though they grabbed them strongly, they got thrown.
It made them wonder a lot.
Besides that, I don't really know.
There was also the baseball's most famous player, Sadaharu Oh.
He was a super hero.
He had a specific way to bat, on one leg.
He hit with one leg up and really threw far.
He learned that from studying Aikido.
[Guillaume] Not from kenjutsu?
No, not that.
It was interesting, a lot of different people were doing it.